more than seven decades after World War
two ended some American servicemen who
lost their lives got a special tribute
Friday and getting them their
recognition has been a lifelong dream
for one man in Sheffield England who was
just a boy during the war Holly Williams
has the story
these Jets will be flying what's known
as the missing man formation 75 years
after an American b-17 bomber named me
amigo
crashed in this English Park the 10 u.s.
airman who died here were honored with a
flyover by American and British military
aircraft down below thousands cheered
the planes and 82 year old Tony folks
[Applause]
thank you I can't believe all this is an
8 year old Tony was in the park playing
with other children the day the me amigo
went down killing all on board it's
Tony's story emerging last month after a
chance meeting with a British journalist
that sparked the campaign for today's
fly past the damaged American bomber
badly shot up by the German Luftwaffe
was apparently attempting an emergency
landing when the crew spotted the
children if I intervene on the park they
could have London on the part the b-17
veered away and crashed into nearby
trees Tony is convinced that the pilot
and all on board died to save the lives
of the children playing in the park and
he told CBS News last month that he
feels responsible visiting the scene of
the crash nearly every day since 1953
there's nothing I love better than for
the American people to realize it wasn't
just a bomb and a crushed
he saved six english nuts on Friday
Tony's wish came true and sharing the
stage with him with family members of
some of the u.s. Airmen who died onboard
them leonito I don't know what I was
expecting but it was more than I ever
could have could have hoped for
an extraordinary act of selflessness and
a man who's never forgotten it finally
given the recognition they both deserve
for CBS this morning Saturday Holly
Williams London I'm sure not a dry eye
in that crowd of thousands what a lovely
ceremony and what an incredible turnout
all these years later yeah that story
and one in one of the stories written
about it he said that he actually
believes that he saw the pilot waving to
try to move those kids